let's go le Punto ça dégage ça dégage
maintenant il prend F3 il fait des6
échec avant il lui marche dessus il lui
marche dessus il sait plus quoi faire
Magnus il sait plus où il habite le fou
qui revient en C4 sur échec Magnus qui
va peut-être abandonner dans quelques
secondes roi C5 c'est quoi le problème
sur B7 il y a pas de problème il y a le
roi qui va monter Magnus qui pousse le
pion le roi qui monte il peut pas
revenir en E6 avec son roi il va
abandonner et il va laisser la victoire
à notre Maxime qui va prendre la tête du
tournoi ro des4 il avance son roi fou F
il bloque tout et c'est Ro et de dames
et de dames
abandon's max let's le ça dégage ça
dégage maintenant le se frérot parce que
tu es en
dessous's